we continue to explore the overlap
between extreme right wing ism
and mental illness
and uh this is a link that we can also
find
on the extremes on the left as well but
it's particularly notable lately on the
right and i have for you today i'm going
to present to you
a new character
this is
susan delemus susan delemus is a new
hampshire state representative
she in the
wake of the forthcoming roe v wade
decision from the supreme court that we
learned about last week protests broke
out all over the country
and
representative susan delemus showed up
at the new hampshire state house and
started screaming at the top of her
lungs i'm a murderer i murdered my own
baby
and this is serious and tragic and it
also looks like a saturday night live
skit quite frankly it's both it's sad
and it's endlessly
uh hysterical in a way so i'm going to
play this for you she showed up and she
started admonishing the pro-choice
protesters calling them murderers and
calling herself a murderer check this
out
[Applause]
so now she's screaming shame on all of
you but then she turns the anger inward
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
i mean
it's impossible not to laugh at the
absurdity of this and also
tragically
she seems like a very unwell person and
this is a real challenge we have right
now
we have to
be
sympathetic
to
severe
illness mental illness without
diagnosing anyone ever of course we
never do that
and at the same time realize that there
is political strength behind this
nuttery i'll give you another example we
looked yesterday at this anti-vaxx stuff
where michael flynn and some guy named
clay i believe his name was were talking
about how
there are um
how do i even explain this
there are particles
injected into the body
in the covet vaccine
which then are which contain marburg
virus which is a phelovirus in the
family of ebola
they inject you with
it's almost like standby particles of
the marburg virus
and then a 5g signal pulsed three times
in a minute will activate the particles
which are on standby and then you will
get marburg virus
that's so crazy you have to laugh at
that that's absurd it's just it's
comical it's it's a comical conspiracy
theory
but also we have to recognize
that seems like mental illness
and
it's a tough thing to do i don't know
what else can be said
uh but whatever susan delemus went
through or is going through
um
hopefully she can get the help she needs
i mean i'm struggling with how to even
say this but
uh
a new hero i guess
of the
anti-choice movement i mean i'm
struggling for uh the language with
which we can really address this
properly but bizarre
and many anti-choicers saying
that's the kind of passion we need
and when i see that i see a very very
sick person let me know what you think
you can find me on twitter at deepakman
if you have thoughts don't feel
obligated you don't have to comment on
every story i also want to remind you
that memorial day monday may 30 memorial
day
we are doing a one day
membership blowout to officially kick
off the primary season we are the
midterm rather we will be beyond many
primaries by then
we are primarily funded by our audience
we want to do
everything we want to cover the debates
we want to cover rallies we're going to
have someone on the ground at the trump
rally this weekend all of these
different things all of these different
things cost money and so we depend on
your support if you've been thinking
well maybe i'll sign up i don't hate
david so much that i wouldn't support
him right
get on my mailing list at
davidpakman.com and then monday memorial
day you'll get an email telling you how
to sign up at an ungodly discount
what if you could get through an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes
blinkist takes top nonfiction books in
every genre boils them down into a text
or audio explainer that you can consume
in 15 minutes of course blinkist would
never replace reading real books in
their entirety but blinkist lets you
absorb the most important insights from
the non-fiction books you wouldn't
otherwise have time for i have a ton of
different ways i consume information and
blinkist is one of those and it's super
efficient i just used blinkist to listen
to the book toxic positivity
super interesting just about this like
happiness obsessed culture that now we
live in got through it in 15 minutes
with all of the key points blinkist also
takes tons of popular podcasts and
creates a 15-minute explainer for each
episode and blinkist really just
empowers you to grow by discovering new
ideas knowledge that will give you
valuable new perspectives about the
world go to blinkist.com pacman to try
blinkist free for seven days and you'll
get twenty five percent off a premium
subscription that's just 625 a month the
link is down below